Lewinsky has said the release of the
Starr report the 445 page report was one
of the worst days of her life she wants
an apology we apologize to her no I want
because unfortunately the facts are the
facts and we were put in the position
that under the statute of which I was
appointed I had a duty I had a
responsibility I will say and I've said
it for many times I regret all the pain
that resulted to so many including to
the nation of course I regret that but
no I can't in conscience say to Monica
anything other than I'm sorry that the
whole thing happened the day that she
was questioned in a hotel room was
dubbed the operation prom night why was
a sting operation necessary it was a
distinction what it was was simply a
mechanism of trying to confirm what we
thought we knew and we did know it these
were in fact the facts and to give her
the opportunity to cooperate with the
investigation had she cooperated this
entire matter would have been wound up
in a matter of several weeks and the
nation would have been spared all this
so we treated her with dignity we
treated with respect and said here is
the possibility you can cooperate with
the investigation which has been
authorized by the Attorney General and
was destined be authorized with a spec
by the special division and now please
cooperate and let's get this over with
can I ask about